et là je me suis dit Patrick pour les
fêtes la bonne idée c'est de mettre tous
les programmes aux couleurs de Noël en
gros on change rien à votre série juste
vous êtes habillé en Père Noël wouh
Patrick c'est du jamais vu mais la série
est déjà tournée malheureusement et ben
on s'en fout on la retourne on la
retourne monsieur yotis c'est pas
monsieur yotis mon prénom c'est pas
naoti j'ai une question Patrick c'est
vous qui qui tenez les reennes de la ch
ah bah qu'est-ce qu'on se poêle tant qu'
être là vous avez pas le 06 derv matou
c'est le 06 c'estàd 06 ne confiez pas
votre imagination à n'importe qui il a
beaucoup de chance même à Noël de
chiffres son
numéro